[Music]
a newly unsealed deposition
offers new insight into jeffrey
epstein's close associate
and former girlfriend gelane maxwell
maxwell gave sometimes evasive
answers in the 2016 deposition taken as
part of a civil suit by epstein accuser
virginia dufrey maxwell is accused of
recruiting underage girls for epstein's
alleged sex trafficking ring
and participating in the sex abuse
herself think about that
however she has long denied any
involvement in this
and our mulalengi continues to follow
the case according to the deposition
gelane maxwell says she knew jeffrey
epstein was a registered sex offender
when asked if she recruited girls on
epstein's behalf
she said i don't recruit anybody and
appeared disgusted
saying i resent and despise the word
recruit
throughout the testimony maxwell dodged
questions about epstein's alleged abuse
of underage girls and repeatedly called
epstein accuser virginia dufrey a liar
maxwell defending herself said i can't
think of anything i have done that is
illegal
while being questioned about her initial
meeting with jufrey maxwell's anger
appeared to boil over
and she harshly pounded the table later
apologizing for the behavior
jufrey alleges epstein and maxwell
sexually abused her when she was
underage
and lent her out to their friends in a
july interview with cbs this morning
drew frey said epstein was a sick
pedophile
but maxwell was the mastermind she is
even
worse than epstein she she put it this
way
epstein was pinocchio and she was
gispetto
pulling the strings yep she was pulling
the strings
she had his money he had her contacts
they made a great
group that way but guilin was much more
conniving and smart than epstein
ever was at one point during the
deposition jufrey's attorney sigrid
mccauley appeared to ask maxwell about
the now infamous picture
of drew frey and the uk's prince andrew
jufrey says she had sex with the prince
at maxwell's london home that night
the prince has repeatedly denied
jufrey's allegations
and maxwell called jufrey's account of
the incident an obvious lie
in the deposition maxwell said jufrey
characterized things took place in my
bathroom
in the bathtub itself the tub is too
small for any type of activity
whatsoever
what was your takeaway of delaine as a
person
she's really intelligent she's perhaps a
bit too clever
she obviously believes that she should
give up
nothing cbs news legal analyst rikki
kleeman
says the deposition could create
problems for maxwell
at trial anything particularly damaging
the jury
is going to wonder why she doesn't have
some kind of story
that is other than everyone else is
lying
in addition pounding on the table
does not get you anywhere in a criminal
court
well in a statement to cbs news virginia
duprey's attorney says
maxwell's deposition is only a fraction
of the evidence against her and as more
is released they say
it'll become increasingly apparent why
maxwell and other epstein enablers
fought so hard
to keep these documents sealed as we've
reported as you know jeffrey epstein
died by suicide while in federal prison
in manhattan
awaiting trial last year meanwhile glenn
maxwell
is in federal prison here in brooklyn
she's been here since july and is
waiting for her trial
which is scheduled for next year tony
very interesting well we know you'll
keep following it for us thank you very
much